here in Berlin millions of tweets and
social media posts go online every day
and some of them are abuse and lies
Yatta come works for a journalist group
called collective she exposes fake news
such as the story about a Syrian refugee
who took a selfie with German Chancellor
Angela Merkel in 2015
yeah Hutton selfing mediocre mock he
took a selfie with her eyes added on a
special and later unfortunately people
accused him online of supposed
involvement in the Brussels terrorist
attacks disposal Hottentots of a
short-lived water a groundless
accusation made by xenophobes another
example of fake news when Hillary
Clinton was running for US president she
was accused of running a child sex ring
these are the kind of stories that Koch
actives fact-checking team aims to
expose it receives funding from the open
society foundation and works with
various news outlets then nine text if
an article or a photo gets more than 500
shares say 10,000 shares then we know
that it's getting a lot of views and we
check to see if the video is real if
it's really what it says it is that it's
not taken out of context and then
Liepaja CEO for example publishes a fact
check that explains whether it's true or
not and in fact them check her vehicle
involved estimate underneath the
fact-checking team at French daily Libre
ser is called these antics it debunks
false claims Twitter and Facebook have
been accused of failing to clamp down on
fake news when they do respond is hugely
due to public pressure they see
themselves as social media platforms
plain and simple
[Music]
Daniel Cunha works for a company on the
outskirts of Berlin that's developed
software for automated Facebook
moderation the software is used by
newspapers and TV broadcasters on their
social media platforms this app allows
web editors to delete a beautif content
when I was act if you don't like a
certain word if it's offensive or a
swear word then you can say no I don't
want this word to appear and the comment
will be deleted from the Facebook page
on their Facebook page in 10 for 260
euros a month converse reo will moderate
10,000 comments social bots are a
particular problem these look like
followers or accounts but generate
messages using algorithms because they
can develop into convincing internet
personas they can actually shape public
opinion phenomena like social BOTS mean
converse REO has its work cut out for it
so the more fake accounts they'll always
be fake accounts at content that turns
out to be fake news so in that sense I
believe that converse REO has a future
to comfort citizens what's true and
what's a lie with the proliferation of
fake news on social media a growing
number of startups have found a niche
cleaning up the Internet
[Music]